bayrischer ministerpräsident csu
vorsitzende dr markus söder und der brk
vorsitzende professor klaus josef lutz
herr doch das wird meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren einen schönen guten tag
deutschland steuert auf eine echte und
nachhaltige notlage zu unserem land geht
stück für stück die energie aus es tut
ein eiskalter winter wirtschaftlicher
stillstand preise die explodieren und
insbesondere für viele normalverdiener
eine abstiegsspirale bedeuten könnten es
ist die zentrale aufgabe der
bundesregierung dafür zu sorgen dass das
warme wohnungen bezahlbares essen und
gesicherte arbeitsplätze gibt zumindest
was die energie betrifft dies ist die
kernaufgabe einer regierung andere
themen sind spannend dies ist der kern
problem ist die strategie gegenüber
russland ist offensichtlich falsch
eingeschätzt worden zu kurzfristig
geplant und jetzt besteht die große
gefahr
dass wir stück für stück abgeschaltet
werden lange wurde die lage schöngeredet
auch etwas vernebelt jetzt langsam kommt
licht hinein der chef der
bundesnetzagentur hat es ja vor wenigen
tagen gesagt in drei monaten können die
deutschen die gaspreise nicht mehr
zahlen er weist auf die preis
explosionen wer das szenario der
bundesnetzagentur sieht weiß das
erheblichste lücke selbst den
optimistischen fällen stattfindet im
grunde genommen droht eine energie oder
eine gasflasche für unser land es ist
jetzt die falsche frage nur zu stellen
was man abstellt sondern die erste frage
muss gestellt werden wann und wo kommt
ersatz wann und wo kommt das jetzt seit
wochen werden möglichkeiten angedeutet
aber keine lösungen gezeigt andere
länder sind schneller italien hat
beispielsweise mit klar sagen wir das
heute gehört die verträge schon
abgeschlossen warum deutschland nicht
statt whatever it takes was wir mal bei
der eurokrise auf die energie anzuwenden
also alles nutzen was möglich ist
verkämpft sich die ampel in kleinen und
zum teil ideologischen graben struktur
wir sind der meinung nichts abschalten
was energie bringt
erleichtern was energie ermöglicht und
bürokratie weit geht nach außen drängen
es ist einfach falsch nur zu sagen kalt
duschen oder bestimmte gerade in der
wohnung zu definieren ja sogar heute
notstromaggregate zu fordern wenn man
gleichzeitig die stromversorgung
abstellt wir halten es und dabei bleibt
es für einen fundamentalen fehler die
kernenergie einfach abzustellen nicht
nur weil es eine zusätzliche stromlücke
für zehn millionen haushalte gibt nicht
nur weil der rest der welt in europa und
darüber hinaus auf kernenergie weiter
setzt sondern auch weil aus dem
gasverstromung erfolgt und allein der
teil könnte gut ersetzte
wir haben es mehrfach erbeten die
bevölkerung übrigens steht mehrheitlich
verhindern dies jetzt abzulehnen ist
nichts anders als ideologische sturheit
wird am ende kein ergebnis bringen die
verantwortung dafür wird enorm sein
widerspruch 1 also warum anatom
abschalten widerspruch 2 warum einzelne
erneuerbare energien die schon da sind
abschalten und schwächen zum beispiel
wasser wir waren uns übrigens muss an
einem sehr sehr ernst und sehr
konstruktiven gespräche mit industrie-
und handelskammern da einig darüber
warum stellt man wasser ab warum wird
ist verschlechtert allein mit dem
repowering der wasseranlagen könnte man
enorme möglichkeiten setzen unsere
nachbarn österreicher schweizer wundern
sich nur warum deutschland eine sichere
energiequelle die funktioniert hat
einfach liegen lässt viele stellen auch
die frage warum die energiereserven die
erdgas in deutschland sind zumindest
nicht mal prüft anstatt zu hoffen dass
ein fünffach teures flüssiggas aus den
usa die lösung bringt für das es noch
kein terminal und letzter punkt wo wie
so vieles gemacht werden kann wäre dass
man durch einfache die ak hat uns das
wirklich sehr praktisch aufgezeigt durch
einfache verfahren der bürokratie die
entbürokratisierung die
umstellungsprozess ezb von gas auf öl
schnell voranbringen könnte nach wie vor
blockieren wir uns
immissionsschutzrechtlich selbst nach
wie vor sind die gesamten möglichkeiten
die wir nutzen können einfach schnell
umzustellen und da jetzt meinen vorrang
zu geben werden nicht genutzt genauso
wenig wie etliche wärmepumpen die
eigentlich schon gebaut sind nicht zur
genehmigung kommen all dies ist blockade
aus den gründen ich nicht sagen kann was
den bürgern wehtut bei einem einzelnen
amerikanischen investor wie tesla wird
alles möglich gemacht bei tausenden von
haushalten in deutschland bei vielen
hunderten mittelständischen betrieben
ist das gegenteil der fall
und eine zusatz sorge die wir in bayern
haben der chef der bundesnetzagentur vor
wenigen tagen nicht nur gesagt dass man
sich auf
das nicht mehr bezahlen können der
gaspreise einstellen muss sondern hat
auch mit einer gewissen häme hinzugefügt
jetzt werden die im süden mal sehen dass
die guten zeiten so ungefähr vorbei sind
das ist nicht akzeptabel
offenkundig hat man da freude oder
zumindest eine absicht jedenfalls kein
ernsthaftes bemühen den süden in
deutschland genau so wahrzunehmen wie
man es im osten norden tut wir fordern
dass massiv ein wer glaubt in süden zu
schwächeln hat keinen vorteil fürs land
wenn die bayerischen blutbahnen
verstopft sind dann gibt es einen
deutschen herzinfarkt denn der süden ist
das ökonomische leistungszentrum unseres
landes deswegen ist das füllen des
gasspeichers und die vereinbarung
zwischen deutschland österreich der
absolute prüfstein für die frage wie
ernst man es nimmt in der gesamten
entwicklung was jetzt bayern und die
bayerische wirtschaft betrifft denn ohne
diesen gasspeicher verstärkt sich die
notlage potenziert sich nochmal ich
erwarte mir übrigens auch ganz ehrlich
das mal die bayerische opposition da
auch aufwacht und mithilft in dem fall
gibt es jetzt keine kleinteiligen
parteiinteressen das sage ich auch wenn
man heute hier sozusagen unsere partei
gedacht sondern gibt es das
staatspolitische interesse dass alle in
bayern gut versorgt werden letzter punkt
das thema nochmal preise übergeben haben
es ist tatsächlich so dass für viele
normalverdiener gar nicht mehr nur für
die unteren sondern für normalverdiener
das nicht mehr schulter pass
normalverdiener haben die gefahr des
sozialen abstiegs man erlebt dass man
hört dass supermärkte mit lebensmitteln
bei energiepreisen ähnliche mehr wir
müssen dagegen steuern wir müssen
gegensteuern das problem ist dass dem
staat den bundesdeutschen staat auch
hier dass die luft ausgeht 300
milliarden schulden zu machen zur unzeit
bedeuten dass jetzt gilt fällt in der
krise zu retten deswegen sollte ja dann
noch mal ein komplettes um steuern
erfolg
investitionen oder außer wien ein euro
ticket für den bayerischen tourismus gut
waren aber glaube ich nicht der
nachhaltigen umstieg auf den öpnv
bringen im gegenteil ich habe so viel
geld gekostet geld fehlt uns jetzt zum
ausgleich
unterstützungsmaßnahmen zu geben wir
brauchen nicht nur begrenzte steuern und
das soll ein nachhaltiges steuersystem
kalte progression abschaffen oder staat
sogar verdient an der inflation sprit
und energie und stromsteuer wunder
setzen damit sie europäisch auch
wettbewerbsfähig sind und wenn man was
tut dann für alle die ihk ist jetzt
nicht der schutzpatron der rentnerband
rentner weiß ich wie sein wenn muss eine
maßnahme von allen getragen werden sonst
wird sie nicht akzeptiert werden und
letzter also allerletzte bemerkung
was mich im moment etwas bewegt ist das
den eindruck man hat die ampel schaltet
auf durchzug sowie bei der
pressekonferenz zum g 7 gipfel nach dem
motto danke für die frage
die ampel zieht im moment ihr ding durch
und selbst wirklich vernünftige einwände
die wir gerade stellen nicht nur
kernkraft sondern auch
genehmigungsrechtliche fragen
wasserkraft die man ja belegen kann ja
nicht so dass deutschland ein großes
großer politischer effekt oder erfolg
dahinter stünde schon gar kein
parteipolitischer die werden einfach
abgeblockt wer abblockt oder wer aus
ideologischen gründen sein ding
durchzieht perfekt waren aber auch das
muss ich ehrlich sagen wir alleine
gefahren worden erreichen immer die hand
es geht für berlin wie bayern sowieso
erreichen immer die hand wir schreiben
briefe wir haben uns in bayern zum
beispiel das war auch ein thema was uns
ja mal vor wochen bewegt hat bei den
erneuerbaren energien massiv bewegt wenn
wir ehrlich sind jetzt beim wind glaube
ich dass wir mit dem konzept das wir
jetzt auf den weg bringen im onshore
bereich riesig aufholen und das wird uns
für die mittelfristige zukunft sehr viel
helfen aber für die nächsten ein zwei
jahre
wenn man den neuen genehmigungs
strukturen wieder zieht kaum wir müssen
uns darauf einstellen dass dieser
wirtschaftskrieg den russland beginnt zu
führen dass wir den auch als solches
begreifen und verstehen dass er länger
geht der wird nicht mit einem
vierteljahr vorbei ist an dem manche
eingeschätzt hat deswegen ist es wichtig
an der stelle statt flickschusterei ein
längerfristiges konzept zu haben statt
nur verzicht zu empfehlen eine
nachhaltige philosophie zu entwickeln
whatever it takes und energie zu bringen
damit dieses land ohne wirtschaftliche
und soziale verwerfungen und am ende
auch demokratische veränderungen gut
über den winter und die nächsten jahre
zu kommen danke der industrie und
handelskammer an der stelle noch einmal
ganz persönlich während der kroner zeit
ist man gemerkt ohne die industrie und
handelskammer werden die vier
hilfszahlungen diese gemanagt haben eine
ganze branchen hätten nicht stattfinden
können es war eine überragende leistung
will ich einfach nochmal sagen ganz
großes komplett mit unseren
staatspolitischen interesse viele
existenzen damit geredet dankeschön
führen dann gehört für das sehr
vernünftige konstruktive aber wenn wir
ehrlich sind auch sorgen reichlich
gespräch danke präsident
herr professor lutz bitte ja dass gott
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
herr ministerpräsident im namen der
bayerischen industrie und handelskammern
darf ich hier einige statements machen
der erste punkt ist wir befinden uns in
der tat in einer in einem
wirtschaftskrieg mit russland und
anderen
die wirtschaft wird das in den nächsten
wochen und monaten spüren die
entscheidenden punkte um sozusagen auf
das wesentliche zu konzentrieren dass
die energieversorgung und die
rohstoffversorgung mit der wir uns
beschäftigen müssen und es reicht
wirklich nicht aus einfach zu sagen kalt
duschen und dann kriegen wir schon hin
ich habe heute früh natürlich kalt
geduscht aber das bringt dann den
kreislauf erst so richtig in wallung und
ich könnte mich in wenigen minuten in
rage reden denn wenn wir hier von einem
wirtschaftskrieg sprechen und wenn wir
davon reden dass ganze
wirtschaftssektoren massiv unter druck
kommen da möchte man kurz beschreiben
was das eigentlich bedeutet wenn wir
nicht die entsprechende gasversorgung
haben wenn wir nicht die
energieversorger und rohstoffversorgung
haben die wir in den verschiedenen
wirtschaftssektoren und industrien
brauchen dann reden wir hier auch
möglicherweise nicht nur über kurzarbeit
bedürfnisse sondern auch über
arbeitslosigkeit und
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die
nicht den lohn und brot gehalten werden
können und der staat darf auf keinen
fall sozusagen die illusion erzeugen das
wird dann alles von den behörden
übernommen was uns der wirtschaft fehlt
ist erstens ein schlüssiges vernünftiges
energiekonzept
des bundes hier im land in bayern das
sind uns auch in vielen punkten wirklich
einige
ministerpräsident auf der bundesebene
sehen wir kein schlüssiges
energiekonzept wo sind die eckpfeiler
wie man sparen kann wie man zum beispiel
die planungsverfahren die
genehmigungsverfahren um zwischen kann
vom gas zu öl das ganze muss vereinfacht
werden um auch die wirtschaft nicht nur
zu unterstützen sondern bestimmte
industriesektoren zu reden ich spreche
stellvertretend zum beispiel über die
glasindustrie ohne gas gibt es kein gras
was das für konsequenzen hat muss ich
ihnen glaube ich im einzelnen nicht
schildern es gibt bis zur frage können
wir im herbst wenn erforderlich eine
impfkampagne starte brauch glasbehälter
dafür oder was passiert in bayern ohne
bier das ist ja alleine schon ein
problem aber noch ernster wird es mit
der nahrungsmittelversorgung meine damen
und herren ohne gas weil viele
unternehmen von öl auf gas versorgung
umgestellt haben weil es vor jahren
politisch gewünscht war wird es
schwierig mit der fleisch versorgung der
milchversorgung der käse versorgung also
mit dem grundnahrungsmittel mit der
produktion der grundnahrungsmittel und
hier hätten wir gerne ein schlüssiges
konzept und die ihk arbeitet nicht nur
mit der bayerischen staatsregierung
zusammen wir bieten natürlich auch an
mit den verantwortungsträgern in berlin
uns zusammenzusetzen oder die ak macht
es ja zum teil zumindest dass man uns
zuhört und b auch dinge endlich
umgesetzt werden wir müssen jetzt wir
haben keine zeit mehr so schnell es geht
wenn energiekonzept vom bund bekommen
dass wir auch wissen was müssen wir tun
was dürfen wir tun was können wir tun
also zum beispiel dieser switch von gas
zu öl auch wenn uns vielleicht öl nicht
wirklich gefällt aber es bleibt doch gar
nichts anderes übrig die kohlekraftwerke
nach oben zu fahren volumen die energie
volumen die hier produziert werden okay
das ist ein schritt man muss auch über
die anderen energieträger sprechen und
das ganze darf nicht ideologisiert sein
denn die ideologie führt am ende zu
nicht nur sozialen verwerfungen sondern
ganze wirtschaftszweige werden so nicht
weiter produzieren können wie heute wir
brauchen natürlich ein beschleunigungs
verfahren für die wind und für die
solar- und für die biomasse also
erneuerbare energien aber das löst nicht
unsere probleme in den nächsten monaten
und der ministerpräsident der wir uns ja
auch einig wir brauchen einzelmaßnahme
kleine maßnahmen und die ergeben dann
ein großes mosaik bild in der hoffnung
dass wir zumindest so einigermaßen und
unsere energie thema kurzfristig in
griff kriegen jetzt auf verträge die
irgendwann 20 24 25 26
alleine zu setzen stichwahl zum beispiel
katar wo wir immer noch keinen vertrag
haben hilft der wirtschaft und damit den
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern und auch
den eigentümern der unternehmen
überhaupt nicht verbrauchen sozusagen
drücken lösungen und da ist die
bundesregierung gefragt und vorletzter
woche zum beispiel
bundeswirtschaftsminister bayern münchen
und spricht von einer vervierfachung des
gaspreises meine damen und herren wir
sind eine exportnation bayern ist ein
exportland wie wollen wir eigentlich im
internationalen konzert bestehen wenn
wir energiekosten haben die überbordend
sind und die wir auch an unsere kunden
so ohne weiteres nicht weitergeben
können international werden wir massiv
unter einen wettbewerbsdruck kommen und
ich kann ihnen versichern wir die
unternehmerinnen unternehmer die manager
wir versuchen natürlich alle register zu
ziehen um unser geschäft zu
diversifizieren die einkaufs strukturen
zu diversifizieren aber gerade auf der
energie seite hängen wir nun mal ob es
uns gefällt oder nicht nach wie vor in
einem hohen maße von russland ab und der
die illusion hatte dass wir dann halt
wärme strom energie aus frankreich zb zu
kaufen dem sei gesagt erstens ca 45
prozent der akw in frankreich sind
stillgelegt aufgrund technischer
probleme aus sicherheitstechnischen
themen zweiter frankreich kaufte selbst
das wird völlig verschwiegen hier gas
aus russland und das gleiche gilt
übrigens auch für polen wir sind also
eigentlich nicht alleine aber es wird
immer so getan als wären wir die
deutschen sozusagen komplett alleine
abhängig vom russischen gas und die
franzosen etf die werden uns dann schon
helfen und neben diesen technischen
problemen die ich erwähnt hat meine
damen und herren haben wir auch noch
klimatische fragen nämlich zb das
niedrigwasser an da war dann haben sie
nicht genug wasser da müssen sie die
reaktoren runterfahren und die franzosen
werden uns sicherlich nicht mit energie
versorgen wenn nicht frankreich selbst
zunächst auch entsprechend geschützt ist
das ist der eine punkt den ich kurz
ansprechen möchte und der zweite punkt
meine damen und herren ist die
rohstoffpolitik es gibt neun kritische
rohstoffe für die insbesondere
bayerische industrie ich meine wir sind
dort ist deutsche high tech center wenn
man hört dass der chef der
bundesnetzagentur solche statements
macht 13 mal zu ihr kam nach münchen
einladen dann kriegt er eine spezial
vorlesung von uns wichtig plan für
deutschland um nicht zu sagen für den
rest der welt ist und ich habe hier ein
chart für diejenigen die sich dafür
interessieren das können wir ihnen der
nicht jetzt hier in der kurzen
ausführung erläutern aber es sind neun
diese roten punkte sollten sie die seen
sind neun
rohstoffe die wir dringend brauchen
vieles davon kommt aus china oder
anderen staaten wo wir nach dem
lieferketten sorgfaltspflichten gesetz
uns die frage stellen müssen dürfen wir
dort überhaupt noch einkaufen 50 prozent
der solarmodule für die energiewende
auch hier bei uns zu hause kommt aus
china für uns stellt sich die frage als
wirtschaft was dürfen wir in der zukunft
überhaupt noch tun was wir wollen ist
eine schwarze eine blacklist sozusagen
wo dürfen wir nicht geschäfte machen
eine whitelist der amerikaner machen mit
wem dürfen wir geschäfte machen das
könnte ich jetzt noch weiter ausführen
würde aber den rahmen sprengen wenn sie
gestatten eine letzte anmerkung meine
damen und herren wir die frage ja immer
kommt die versorgung mit nahrungsmitteln
ist die situation für uns schwierig ist
sie gefährlich ich habe das schon in
anderen zusammenhang mehrfach gesagt
erstens wir gehen davon aus dass die
versorgungslage in deutschland
mindestens erstes quartal 23
sicher ist aber dann kommt sofort das
thema wie schaut's international aus
hunger in afrika in nordafrikanischen
ländern den schwarzafrikanischen staaten
in asiatischen staaten da kann ich ihnen
sagen es gibt eine analyse die vor
einigen tagen veröffentlicht wurde wir
gehen davon aus 17 prozent weniger
getreide erträge in der ukraine als im
letzten jahr teilweise haben die russen
getreide
getreidebestände vor allem im osten
abgezogen nach unseren erkenntnissen und
vermutungen aber der entscheidende punkt
ist die logistik funktioniert nicht
odessa ist vermint und mir ganzzügen
alleine werden wir das hungerproblem auf
dieser welt nicht lösen können kurzum es
besteht nicht nur die problematik für
uns wirtschaftskrieg mit russland ettal
sondern es besteht auch das große risiko
dass in weiten teilen der welt die
mengen an brotweizen insbesondere es
gibt aber auch für mais und raps aus
europa und die ukraine gehört zu europa
nicht geliefert werden können mit den
entsprechenden negativen auswirkungen
ich danke ihnen
vielen dank gibt es fragen von ihrer
seite ich verbitte vom bayerischen
rundfunk
denn forderung in der csu die sie als
ihk nicht mittragen
wir haben ein hohes maß an
deckungsgleichheit es gibt sicherlich
einzel er keine themen aber im großen
und ganzen sind wir uns
wirtschaftspolitisch gottseidank einig
und es ist auch wichtig dass die
staatsregierung schrägstrich die csu als
der wichtigste teil wenn ich das so
sagen darf der bayerischen
staatsregierung die ak dass sich eine
deckungsgleichheit haben denn wenn wir
uns auch noch rum streiten würden und
als berlin kommt zunächst wir haben
gottes würden dafür sagen wir waren
übrigens auch sehr dankbar für die
beratung auch im prozess der
erneuerbaren energien weil für uns auch
bei der reform beim wind die
stellungnahmen von ihk und den
arbeitgebern und der wirtschaft sehr
sehr wichtig waren es war auch teil des
prozesses bei uns da einen großen
schritt voran zu gehen das wollte ich
mal ausdrücklich sagen weil da gab es ja
debatten
und es war für uns auch wichtiger
prozess da nochmal dankeschön dafür
betrifft stefan marktanteile wanderte
herr professor lutz es gibt das erste
unternehmen die sagen wir schicken
wieder mitarbeiter mittelfristig ins
home office gar nicht mal wegen corona
sondern um energie zu sparen müsse man
die büros nicht heizen und so weiter ist
ein gangbarer weg der wirklich was
bringen würde wie schätzen sie das ein
das muss man natürlich im genau im
detail untersuchen allerdings ich
überschrift das alles was hilft jetzt
energie zu sparen ist gut ist positiv
ich kann für die unternehmen für die
normalerweise sozusagen hauptberuflich
spreche dass nichts sagen dass wir hier
die mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter nach hause
schicken wir hatten zwei jahre home
office zeit und der soziale kontakt aber
auch dass der intellektuelle austausch
im hinblick auf geschäftsmodelle neue
produkte innovationen das können sie
nicht nur online über teams meetings und
ähnliches machen wir brauchen die
gespräche also wenn das design oder und
andere unternehmen macht okay vor allem
personalintensive
unternehmen da glaube ich wird es
schwierig werden also ich würde mein
unternehmen zu nicht empfehlen außerdem
ob es wirklich zu einer positiven
energiebilanz dann unterm strich wird da
ich meine zweifel ob es vor allem
bereich das ist natürlich ist alles
alles nicht falsch das was uns so
beschwert ist das sozusagen das
scheinbar das konzept ist und das wird
nicht funktionieren also sie werden bei
solchen explosionsartige entwicklung der
30 und dem abbruch des energie strom ist
werden sie damit nicht lösen sie können
versuchen ein bisschen weniger zu
dämpfen aber es wird nicht lösen wenn
die wirtschaft zum beispiel keine
energie hat er nützt ja nichts wenn du
über 19 gerade in der wohnung sitzen
keinen arbeitsplatz mehr ist also dass
das hilft dann nichts mehr
lisa weiß vom bitte
eine frage an sie beide sie hatten ja
davon gesprochen dass die preise
gestiegen sind dass die preise weiter
steigen was halten sie dann beide von
der geplanten konzertierten aktionen der
bundesregierung ist das der richtige weg
ist es auch richtig dass für alle auf
einmal abzufragen das leben als
arbeitgeber zuerst
wir fordern eine ganz andere dinge
wichtig ist dass wir auf das neuerlichen
ebene jetzt einige reformschritte
einleiten die kalte progression muss
beendet werden und es sollten auch keine
kurz und schnellschüsse seien im sinne
von das nummer drei oder vier monate
sondern wir brauchen eine langfristige
längerfristige reform die immer wieder
angepasst werden kann dass es schon klar
aber im grunde vor allem die kalte
progression die spült ja auch noch
sozusagen geld in die staatskassen
aufgrund der inflation und zum teil auch
der nachfrage je nachdem was wir gerade
erleben und ich glaube da wäre der
richtige ansatz
gespräche
mit arbeitnehmern und arbeitgebern sind
immer wichtig haben wir machen den
bayern auch wir haben ja schon vor einer
woche das gemacht das gespräch dort war
von seiten der beiden tarif hat man
zunächst einmal große zurückhaltung weil
sie gesagt haben tariffragen müssen die
tarifparteien lösen und nicht der staat
insofern ist die frage was das angebot
sein kann mein eindruck ist wenn es zum
beispiel einmal ganz gut wenn die
bundesregierung auch mit der position
reden würden so eine notlage ja auch mal
eine konzertierte aktion findet nicht
statt letzte woche haben also gar nichts
mehr zeit gehabt nach bayern zu kommen
zum termin mit dem freistaat bayern soll
am abend zu einem
netten abendessen habe ich gehört dass
weiß nicht was da war so also das test
ist das erste problem ist zweiter ich
glaube tatsächlich der staat soll
zunächst im schnellsten kann und das ist
was wir vorhin gemeint haben diese
kleinen diese ganzen kleinen aktionen
wie sie die alle nicht falsch sind also
ganz nett sind aber noch mal neu rot ist
ein musterbeispiel für bayern ist es
noch relativ super weil weil das hilft
uns ein bisschen im tourismus durch
bayern zu fahren aber das löst natürlich
die probleme nicht oder tankwarte für
drei monate lösen natürlich nicht das
problem man muss sich auf eine
längerfristige strategie einstellt das
ist das was der eigentliche vorwurf ist
es ist falsch eingeschätzt worden dass
ein solcher konflikt mit russland denn
wenn man eingeht auch bestehen muss dass
der einen längerfristigen atem braucht
und nicht so eine kurzfristige
kurzfristige debatte und da glaube ich
fehlt im moment das ist das wo wir auch
nicht wissen was die strategie ist auch
reicht ein terminal und vor allem bei
uns was ist mit den süd anbindungen
selbst kohlekraftwerke die jetzt im
norden oder westen angeschlossen werden
sind für uns zum teil gar nicht nutzbar
weil die energieversorgung nicht zu uns
kommt was ist eigentlich mit dem betrieb
dem bemühen mit italien auch hier
verbinden uns dann bislang ist nichts zu
hören wir bekommen vom bund da nichts
hören und dieses gefühl dass schröder
mal sagte steine statt brot drängt sich
bei uns immer mehr auf deswegen müssen
wir auch an der stelle neben den briefen
die welt schreiben neben den fragen den
wir stellen auch die öffentlichkeit noch
herbeiführen uns bewegt sich leider
nichts und deswegen konzertierte aktion
ist immer gut zu reden das angebot des
staates muss dann klar definiert sein
aber wie gesagt eigentlich konzertierte
aktion wäre man in deutschland damit zu
arbeiten dass man auf ein einheitliches
gemeinsames ziel kommt denn jetzt ist
echter die stunde von wirklicher von
umfragen von parteitaktik von
beliebtheitsskala alles schön und gut
aber völlig irrelevant instanz
vielleicht millionen von deutschen bald
sehr sehr schlecht gewesen zum beispiel
den ansatz bei den beiden
wasserkraftanlagen 60 prozent davon
stehen in bayern die bundesregierung hat
gesagt ja es ist nicht wirklich
nachhaltig oder green wie kann das sein
also wir fordern auch hier eine
korrektur aber das muss teil eines
gesamten energiekonzeptes sein alles
andere stückwerk und wir erstellen so
vor uns her die lage ist viel zu ernst
und jeder von uns wird davon betroffen
sein
alexander prüfung zdf bitte
ich hätte eine frage an beide herren
also da zunächst mal an sie es geht um
das thema atomkraft haben wir gerade
nochmal wiederholt dass sie dafür sind
die kernkraftwerke länger laufen zu
lassen
jetzt gab es da ja auch einige betreiber
sogar die gesagt haben das bringt im
grunde genommen nichts sie haben
wartungs fragen ins feld geführt sie
haben die brennstäbe romandie herbekommt
ins feld geführt und herr lutz mich
würde ihre meinung dazu interessieren
wie stehen sie zu der forderung die
kernkraftwerke länger laufen zu lassen
und welche erfahrungen oder studien
haben sie angestellt ist das möglich ist
das nicht möglich wie ist ihre meinung
aber die sache ist relativ einfach erst
vor wenigen tagen hat bei preussen
elektra gab es die aussage dass das
natürlich möglich ist wenn man das will
das argument das erste argument war man
hat nicht genügend leute also
abgeschaltete kohlekraftwerke kammern
reaktivieren kernkraftwerke soll man
nicht laufen lassen obwohl die leute
schon da sind ist ein völliger
widerspruch
zweitens es gab das argument ja die
prüfung durch den tüv müssten dann
durchgeführt wenn besagt dieser tüv
süddeutschland hat in seinem gutachten
gesagt bekämen jetzt zum beispiel mit
den vorhandenen brennstäben gut über den
winter ins frühjahr hinein wenn wir
jetzt zusätzlich brennstäbe bestellen
sind wir für die nächsten zwei jahre
sicher auch das ist doch es geht auch
nicht darum zu glauben dass dann in
einem viertel oder einem halben jahr des
bnd sei wenn man mal anschaut die
kraftreserven russlands bestehen weniger
in einer klugen strategie wie man
erkennt aber ein unglaublicher
materialschlacht und da ist anscheinend
enorm viel material worden also brauchen
wir einen langen atem und für uns so
werte eintreten zu können weil ansonsten
wird übrigens die möglichkeit in
deutschland in bestehen dieses konflikts
dramatisch wachsen deswegen die
kernkraft jetzt abzustellen ist für uns
rein ideologisch motiviert wenn man mit
grünen unter der hand rede sagen die
einen ja auch natürlich wäre es jetzt
denkbar aber das spreng es so zu sagen
dass das grüne die die grüne seele und
das kann es ja nicht sein also im
inneren befindlichkeiten der grünen kann
deutschland ständig leiden wir deutlich
sagen die wirtschaft steht hinter den
plänen dass wir die energieversorgung
wie die ganze wirtschaft nachhaltiger
ausrichten müssen dazu gehört natürlich
auch das thema atomkraft wir haben uns
damit
arrangiert abgefunden viele finden es
auch sehr gut da gibt es auch kein
einheitliches bild dass die atomkraft
nicht die basis der energieversorgung
der wirtschaft sein wird in der zukunft
nur wir sind jetzt in einer notsituation
und in der notsituation muss man halt
entsprechend agieren entsprechend
handeln und ich bin der auffassung die
herr söder wenn die drei atomkraftwerke
schon laufen und andere kohlekraftwerke
müssen wir sozusagen von 0 hochfahren
das ist ja völlig absurd dass nicht
weiterlaufen zu lassen wenn das ganze
technisch funktioniert noch mal auf die
atomkraft wo wir uns heuchlerischer
darauf verlassen haben aus frankreich
können wir uns nicht verlassen weil die
blumen einfach nicht 1000
ich sehe keine weiteren fragen dann
tanken und fürs kommen und noch einen
schönen tag schönen tag
diesmal kurz